the backlash is coming by the way with
regard to the the black lives matter
movements propaganda about police
the backlash is coming because it turns
out that crime rates have been rising
dramatically around the united states
the us according to cnn saw a
significant crime rise across major
cities in 2020
according to cnn major american cities
so a 33 increase in homicide last year
okay that is because of the attempt to
absolutely hamstring the cops and make
it impossible for them to do their jobs
you think people are going to go along
to get along on these particular issues
tom cotton is getting dragged through
about the senator from arkansas because
he tweeted out we have a major
under-incarceration problem in america
and it's getting worse
and we were like well yeah we already
incarcerated a lot of people the
question isn't how many people we
incarcerate the question is how many of
those people are innocent
answer not a lot and how many people who
are guilty are out walking the streets
answer some there's a very simple
question to ask when it comes to under
incarceration versus over-incarceration
it is not percentage of people
incarcerated it's percentage of people
who committed crimes in jail
that's the only question i care about if
you committed a murder
i don't care if we have more people in
jail than other countries you should be
in jail you committed a murder
so tom cotton on the numbers is correct
if there's a 33 percent increase in
homicide that means
too few people are in jail at least when
it comes to homicide
okay but it doesn't matter because again
the left can't stop itself in corporate
america that ship can't be turned
in the media they cannot rester
themselves because they've dedicated
themselves to activism
the biden administration can't turn away
from its own radicalism
and the criminal justice system the
black lives matter movement can't steer
away from its own radicalism this is how
you end up with videos of blm activists
saying that cities will burn if derek
schauvin isn't convicted how do you
think this is going to play
you think he's gonna play in america do
you think it's really gonna go well for
you
here is this blm activist if george
floyd's murderer
is not sentenced just know that all hell
is gonna break loose don't be surprised
when buildings on fire
okay so here's the thing as i've been
pointing out this whole time and i think
most people
who have a brain are noticing is that
this shalvin case
is not clear cod not only is it not
clear cut yesterday happened to be a
particularly bad day for the prosecution
in the in the derek shalvin murder case
with regard to george floyd
there are a bunch of witnesses who were
interviewed yesterday and it did not
turn out well for the prosecution in
fact it turned out so not well for the
prosecution that one of the witnesses
the prosecution called
the defense announced they wanted to
recall the witness as a defense witness
that's how badly it went for the
prosecution you know the prosecution is
doing a crappy job when they call a
witness
and the defense cross-examines the guy
and they're like you know what we like
you so much we want you back
on our side like that ain't good the
state called
a minneapolis police department
lieutenant named johnny marshall who's a
use of force trainer
and the and the prosecution asked him a
bunch of questions about whether shalvin
was using approved use of force
procedures
but then eric nelson who is the defense
attorney began
asking questions related to mercel's
time as a street cop this according to
legal insurrection.com who's been
doing good job analyzing this on a
day-to-day level
nelson asked questions related to
merciless time as a street cop with a
particular emphasis on the tendencies of
suspects being subject to arrest to come
up with all kinds of nonsense about why
they shouldn't be arrested that day
dangerous job being a police officer yes
are people unhappy about being arrested
very rarely are they happy said mercel
these suspects frequently engage in a
wide variety of behaviors to avoid
arrests including fighting
arguing and making excuses yes they do
answered mercel indeed when asked if he
himself had ever disbelieved a suspect's
claim of a medical emergency
in an apparent effort to avoid arrest
mercel answered he had personally done
so
all of this undercuts the part of the
prosecution narrative that is relying on
floyd's reported pleas and excuses about
claustrophobia
and anxiety and crying out for his
mother perhaps that's real but a
reasonable officer
has to consider maybe it's an effort to
avoid arrest
nelson also once again put the use of
pressure and body weight techniques in a
favorable favorable light
the state wants to present chauvin's
knee in a negative light as deadly
mechanical asphyxiation or as a blood
choke
as attested to by this other witness
derrick williams in fact however the use
of pressure and body weight to restrain
a suspect was adopted by the mpd because
it was a less
intense use of force than prior practice
of using strikes
either bare-handed or batons or even
with weighted gloves to compel
compliance
mercel concurred the take-home message
for the jury is that shelvin's knee far
from being a public execution in a
public street was a lesser force than
would otherwise have been required
so bottom line is this prosecution is
not particularly going well
for the prosecution nelson explored with
mercel whether there were circumstances
in which it would be appropriate for an
officer to maintain a neck restraint for
a substantial period of time
mercel said yes sometimes to maintain
the neck restraint for however long it
took ems to arrive as nelson mercill
answered that he personally
had maintained restraint on suspects for
the duration required
for ems to arrive the state's own use of
force expert testified on cross he
personally had engaged in the exact same
activity that chalvin is currently being
demonized for
that is not a good day for the state as
legal insurrection points out
so again it was just a very very bad day
for the prosecution the reason that i'm
pointing
this out is because what you're hearing
from the media is that this is gonna
the shelvin doesn't get convicted it's a
referendum on american racism cops are
all bad
fewer cops on the street you think this
isn't gonna backfire it's gonna backfire
it absolutely will backfire on the left
because
all they would have to do is say listen
we're gonna look at the facts of the
case and we have a jury system for a
reason they can't do that
they have to say that this is deep
american racism regardless of whatever
the evidence shows
and again it wasn't just that it went
badly for that state's witness
there's another state's witness mpd
officer nicole mckenzie who's the
medical support
coordinator according to legal
insurrection
mckenzie did really poorly on direct
the prosecutor had mackenzie testify
about how officers had a duty of care to
suspects that chevin had cpr and other
training that would qualify him to
provide emergency
care and that such care must be provided
by the officer even if an ambulance had
already been called
isn't it true nelson then asked
mackenzie that you train officers to
consider not just the suspect but the
totality of the scene she said yes
isn't it true that police officers have
a competing duty of safety to themselves
partners bystanders paramedics
to the point that if the scene is unsafe
if the officers haven't already
announced a code for all safe
emts will stage a distance away until
they are told safety has been achieved
yes said mackenzie isn't it true safety
concerns might not come from the suspect
from
but from the crowd yes okay and by the
way
the mob was there shouting at i mean
that's why we have tape
shouting at chavin the entire time which
prevents the mts from getting it
all of this generates at least a picture
of reasonable doubt
all of this pictures at least the
possibility of reasonable doubt
so it's you know none of this is going
particularly well for the state
and if this results in more riots if
this results in more calls for the end
of policing in america it ain't going to
go well for the left either
okay the the left is overreaching on
every area in american life right now
you knew it was coming it is coming and
the backlash is going to be extremely
strong
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content